hey youtubers is charlie so there are a
couple things coming up in the next
couple of days so for my first video
today I just wanted to do a breakdown of
what's coming up when to watch it what's
going on if you guys haven't been
following fear the walking dead it
actually premieres on Sunday night on
AMC it airs at the same time every week
that the walking dead normally airs
there's going to be six episodes and
then we'll get the walking dead season
six premiere but this Sunday like during
the fear the walking dead premiere
they're doing something special there's
going to be a talking dead right before
the episode that'll be a season 6
preview so this sunday night we'll get
new Walking Dead Season 6 footage and
then you'll get an hour-long episode of
fear the walking dead so I'm going to be
doing two walking dead videos that night
or you know one of them might roll into
Monday morning just if I don't get it
done in time I'll do my season 6 preview
video for whatever new footage that they
pose for season 6 then I'll do my fear
the walking dead premiere video just
like during the normal season I'm going
to be doing a weekly giveaway for that
show but the good thing is is it's
almost like there's 22 episodes of the
walking dead because the shows are
connected but they probably won't cross
over till season to fear the walking
dead is a prequel and they're kind of on
opposite coasts like fear The Walking
Dead takes place at Los Angeles and the
survivors right now are up near
Washington DC so get hype about that
it's gonna be a lot of fun they have
some really good actors if you don't
know about the timeline it takes place
when rick is in the coma that that's
kind of where it falls in the time like
this first season if you're confused
about why there's only six episodes
remember when walking dead season one
air they only aired six episodes and
then when they get the season two they
gave them a full series order AMC isn't
just like rolling in money so they like
to try stuff out before they give it
like a full series order next up Tuesday
like next Tuesday like a couple days
after fear The Walking Dead is the Vixen
premiere now this is a little bit
different too it's a digital animated
series meaning that it's kind of air on
the web it's not going to air on TV it
takes place inside the flash and arrow
universes it's connected with those
shows Stephen Amell aunt grant gustin
did the voices for their characters
which will be in the show it's going to
be an origin story for the Vixen
character if you don't know who she is i
did a video breaking her down i'll put a
link in the description she's been a
part of Justice League but she's she's a
magic base character her power comes
from
magic totem so they're using her to
introduce magic in a really big way in
the air on flash universe there'll be
six five minute episodes I know that
seems really short but it'll be like 1
30 minutes story broken into six
episodes if it's successful I don't know
what they consider successful then she
has the chance to make it to a
live-action show so please support this
show like we want to see a live action
version of the character in the air and
flash universe and this is the CW so it
would definitely crossover with those
shows so fixin Tuesday night on CWC com
now if you're an international person
I've got a lot of questions like if it's
available outside the United States you
probably have to use a VPN workaround
I've never tried to access CWC from
outside the United States but if you've
ever tried to watch an animated series
and you live outside the US you probably
just have to watch it the same way you
watch those other shows so do whatever
you gotta do I will not judge just
please I ask that you don't share
streaming links or like our pirate links
inside the comments just like with fear
The Walking Dead will get those six
episodes of vixen one each week and then
at the end of that will get the premiere
of flash and arrow like the new seasons
those are the two really big things that
are happening in the next couple of days
there are like a whole bunch of their TV
shows that i'm watching right now that
i'm not doing videos for like like mr.
robot I beginning a lot of requests for
videos I'm probably not going to do
videos for it is a really interesting
show I usually I usually watch like at
least five or ten TV shows at a time but
I only do videos for about half of them
so for the time being i'll just say if
you're not watching mr. robot definitely
check it out it's a lot of fun it
remains to be seen whether or not the
payoff will be as good as some of the
setups they've had the show makes really
good use of unreliable narration because
because the character is always really
drugged up it's actually good homework
for Game of Thrones because a lot of
people aren't used to the idea of
unreliable narration get characters that
Miss remember things in a lot of you
guys have been asking me about the
expanse that's a new sci-fi series 2 i'm
definitely going to watch it I don't
know if I'm going to make videos for it
it's still a little ways off so I just I
usually wait to like the last minute to
decide and yes I am going to be doing at
least a couple videos for heroes reborn
it's going to overlap with a couple
other shows that I already do but I feel
like they got rid of a lot of the
terrible people from the original hero
series so I am I'm excited to see if
some of the new characters
I'm still doing a DC QA tonight so feel
free to leave any questions on Suicide
Squad Batman V Superman i did a flipper
hands rumor video yesterday so i mean
there's still a lot of talk going on
about that now so we can continue that
in my Q&A video tonight be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos from
that stuff if you're not sure what i'm
going to be posting videos are like what
videos i work on each day I usually let
people know on Twitter and Facebook
their links for that in the description
too I'm really proud of my captain
america civil war thorsday post happy
thursday everybody so why you guys wait
for all that new TV to start coming you
can click here to learn all about the
Vixen series i just do a break down to
the trailer in her origin story in the
comics and you can click here for new
footage from the flash season 2 thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight